on espère rester là pour longtemps mais
c'est vrai que ça tout le lois ça risque
de remettre en cause notre immigration
les projets d'achat d'une maison
viennent de s'envoler pour le
ricarbonara et sa famille arrivée il y a
moins d'un an ils ont quitté leur maison
en France avec le désir de s'établir ici
c'est pas du donantonance et on nous
accepte pour la main d'oeuvre mais par
contre on nous empêche d'accéder à la
propriété le riz devra patienter car
avec le moratoire imposé par Ottawa
seuls les citoyens canadiens ou les
résidents permanents peuvent acheter un
bien immobilier résidentiel quelques
exceptions sont tout de même prévues à
la loi sur l'interdiction d'achat
d'immeubles résidentiel par des noms
Canadiens les résidents temporaires les
réfugiés ou les membres des Missions
Étrangères pourront devenir propriétaire
le ricarbonara et son conjoint pourrait
donc réaliser leurs rêves à Longueuil
mais seulement après avoir travaillé
trois ans au Canada cette frustrant
parce qu'on avait vraiment l'espoir
d'être exempté de de cette loi sachant
que c'est une loi qui vise à limiter la
spéculation la spéculation elle vient
pas des familles modestes qui cherchent
à acheter de la résidence principale
selon la Société canadienne d'hypothèque
et de logement les étrangers
représentent entre 1 à 2% des
propriétaires résidentiels des grandes
régions métropolitaines du pays les
condominium sont très prisés et certains
endroits sont plus populaires que
d'autres pour ce type de logement à
l'île des sœurs les noms Canadiens sont
propriétaires de 7,8% des copropriétés
dans le centre de Toronto
4,1% des condos appartiennent à des
étrangers et il serait 2,7% dans la
péninsule burrent avant couvert mais la
pandémie est venue ralentir le phénomène
on entend plus parler d'achat des
étrangers c'est vraiment un achat qui
est dû au Canadien donc en fait cette
loi elle vient pas forcément régler ce
problème elle vient empêcher que les
étrangers amènent un problème par dessus
le problème et on a vu dans la région
d'Ottawa des gens qui déménageaient
pendant la pandémie de Toronto qui
payait des prix fou de des standards
d'Ottawa parce que pour eux déjà en
venant de Toronto c'était tellement
moins cher le parce qu'elle n'aurait pas
entamé un processus d'immigration si
cette loi avait été en vigueur lors de
ses démarches elle a tout de même espoir
que des changements seront apportés à la
loi pour aider les travailleurs
immigrants comme elle ici Carla Oliveira
Radio-Canada Longueuil